foreign
okay hello everyone we are doing a open
language design review this is part of
our incremental language development uh
series and we have a variety of topics
here
spoken string
that is really lame
right so this was an example that was
fed to us here uh and we have Francisco
and I believe Danielle also uh
potentially talk about this
I wasn't in the meeting where this
originally came up but uh
obviously a sub-optimal results
only to add that we were already doing
some changes in a spoken string
in now Branch we have all these changes
and we haven't yet got into this option
of real position limit so so this is a
good opportunity to to decide what to do
well it was pretty simple I mean
I mean
I don't understand what what is the I
mean
but I mean this is just wrong this thing
here
I mean the default
what's the default value oh I see the
default value of real Precision limit is
three well that's kind of crazy
it should be automatic
right the port should be automatic and
if there's an explicit
Precision I say read all the digits
you know
yeah I agree so if a number comes with
five digits of precision will show the
five if there are 10 10 or whatever
right yeah I mean if it has an explicit
Precision tagging as opposed to dollar
machine Precision but because I mean if
I say precision
of n of Pi
it's machine Precision so machine
precision
right I mean I think what's weird here
like for for example the option print
Precision right that only affects
machine Precision numbers
right if you do style of n
by with print Precision goes to five
you'll see five digits but if you do n
of Pi back you know n of Pi comma 10
with inside of the same style you'll see
10 digits
yeah so what's your point I mean look my
point is that I think it's odd that this
thing
applies to both machine precision and
arbitrary Precision numbers as opposed
to just machine Precision numbers yeah
so that's what we should do
I mean
machine Precision limit
so this option will apply only to the
machine Precision values like the front
end for example when you yes and if
you've got some other thing with 10 000
digits then read 10 000 digits
I I can't see any reason why you would
want to not do that
see what I'm saying
well if it were actually
spoken you know if you ran speak of this
you wouldn't want to read 10 000 digits
yeah but I think there's a different
thing which is spoken strain arguably
should have some overall limit
that's a different thing I mean I'm not
sure that it's worth us worrying about
this right now but I can see that
there's a similar there's a similar
issue with integers right like if you
have you know a million factorial or
something you don't want it to actually
you know they wouldn't want to speak
that giant integer either I don't know
if this oh it has an integer limit
yeah and also there is a string length
limit which I I guess that's the one
that maybe we should play more with that
option
I I mean right
look I think this is one of these things
where it isn't broken I mean let's not
hyperventilize about fixing it let's fix
this particular issue and let's not
worry about anything else
okay okay that's fine
and I mean maybe we should say machine
Precision limit and we should say real
Precision limit as a separate thing and
default it to Infinity
I'll give him Precision number
what's that
no no that I think would be better to
have automatic value for which
for the real Precision limit
no but I'm saying that we want you want
to switch if you have machine Precision
with three digits if you have arbitrary
Precision specified just like with
entity limit and so on that you don't
want to go on for two years reading
stuff
that's what I'm saying so breaking it
into two options
yeah that makes sense yeah
so real Precision limit
and something like machine Precision
limit
okay let's move on
string transform
so this is partly from going through low
hanging in some of our other outstanding
tickets but we have a handful of
existing string transformation functions
that either deal with capitalization or
encoding and a bunch of proposed or
semi-greenlet functions that deal with
variations and what I'm wondering is you
know we've looked at those individually
but holistically do we want to have some
sort of parent string transform or text
transform function and have different
methods of converting it or do we really
want to have a URL encoding a
sluggifying function capitalizing you
know I think so what is what is
it means so a slug is like in typography
like a hyphen or an underscore it's to
connect words together so like URL
sluggifying is removing spaces and
putting hyphens or underscores yeah I
think there are different categories of
thing here I think there are things
where
it is a
I mean something like capitalize
decapitalize
kind of makes sense as a first class
yeah I think so right and they also
understand what that is I mean camel
eyes I can I can sort of yeah but these
are these are older but string smooth
and string contract I have no idea what
those are going to do yeah I have no
idea either
oh
I like string implode and string explode
as names I have no idea what they do but
yeah what do they do
so I believe those ones are actually in
low hanging that we'll be looking at all
right okay fine I personally favor
stringing code string D code as a
generic thing in which we give you know
camel case sluggified
Etc et cetera Etc as the destinations
because I think that a typical thing is
you've got text and you want to do
something like you want to create a URL
you want to encode that string in some
way
[Music]
um
and um
you know you choose different things you
want to
for the encoding but they're all sort of
the same idea
so that will be my
um
well one point might be that they're
they're cases where I don't have these
are really different but there are cases
where it's like you have a big thing of
text like the where is it the email
quote unquote
uh and then there are other cases where
like for example I have something in
camel case and I want to convert to
snake case or something like that where
it's more of a you know you have like a
limited string it's more of a conversion
I know I I think that I think I agree
with you and I think that and code
decode should probably mostly deal with
the short case of you've got one
sentence you want to put dashes you want
to put camel casing those kinds of
things because I think that's what most
of these are the email quote unquote
thing is is a quite is a different thing
and I don't know whether there's a
category of things like that we can
decide that later
because that to me is more anyways more
text related than it is a string related
thing because it's something that
involves you know lines and things like
that
as opposed to the the pure they want to
make this camel case or I want to you
know put dashes and so on well so what's
the distinction then between camel case
maybe something camel case and
capitalize other than just the
capitalized is a more common you know
human understood thing
but I think capitalizes with separate
words whereas camel case is the words
are smooshed
okay so look no and I understand what
the difference between the functions
will be but but the question is if both
of them basically take a bunch of words
separated by spaces you know and one of
them capitalizes the first letters in
some way and the strung in code should
allow capitalize as a second as a string
second argument so I'm just asking that
what is the what is the the reasoning
behind which capitalize also gets its
own function when cam location because
it's popular okay fine camel case you
know the camel is just not such a
popular animal
fine
um
one other thing would be what about
cases where it's more of a conversion
operation than just an encoding like the
case of convert it from snake case to
camel case what a snake case
that's like underscores
I mean there are a lot of cases like
that where you can probably figure out
what the input encoding is but there
might be other cases where you need to
know you know you know the second
argument could be a rule you could do
stringing code snake to camel
yeah but then it sounds like maybe it
could be string convert instead of the
code I agree right and yeah yeah I I was
going to also raise the objection that
you know string in code sounds like it
might be similar to Basin code
but it's really okay it's more string
convert
although I don't really completely like
the word convert because these are very
and that suggests a very heavyweight
operation these are very superficial
operations transform now well that's
what you've got here but I think that's
too fancy last transform
um
I don't think convert cents particularly
heavy weights I mean it doesn't sound
any heavier weight than in code
Translate
that's languages yeah
so you say string convert
yeah I guess I don't know
what other words over there
um I assume if there was a convert there
wouldn't be a decode also yeah that's
right that wouldn't be a decode
string altar
um
a little bit too a little vague alter it
how
okay we've got string transform there
transmute
the
string conventioned
I think that's really obscure
should it be string or text
string
although there are probably going to be
some operations that are very text-like
like you know title case or something
like that
don't we have a title case mechanism
right now
to capitalize I mean these are all
dealing with like Words separated by
spaces and it kind of feels like text
well no not if it's the snake case to
camel case
because there's not words they're just
separated by different things like
underscores or something yeah it's not
just like strings of characters they're
words with semantics what is the generic
name for things like snake case
cases
that sounds like grammar though
string case convert or text case convert
I think case the the cases
no I mean I mean like I was right see
this is why I was trying to get
convention in there right because you
have a camel case convention you have a
uh
[Music]
uh right the snake location it's a title
case a convention Maybe
yeah that's uh that's a Chicago Manual
of style
convinced I'll convert
string rendering convert string
it kind of like style convert
yeah I think Style's not bad although it
does sound a bit like you're gonna make
it red exactly yeah
by the way just the Wikipedia page for
you know camel case snake case Etc is
called naming convention programming
so we could do string convention convert
maybe we need a better list of exactly
what operations we want to support
before we uh
come up with the name
I mean they're mostly space
right yeah I think both snake case and
Kebab case are basically versions of
slugifying
string wood
I don't know okay look it's going to be
one of these things like string style
convert or string
I just think string transform sounds too
General
okay like it I said we can work on
enumerating exactly okay
I guess we're on to low hanging now
so we bring up low hanging here
and how long have these things been
hanging have they rotted on the tree yet
um any of the rotted things we've
basically tried to prune off into the
dead category at the bottom okay all
right okay so so we should we we just
start
where do we start here we start here uh
so reviewed were the ones we looked at
already so yeah needs review is our
personal identifier as our first one
huh
so this should understand what this is
supposed to be this is a canonical
representation of a person with their
honorifics and with their first name
last name and so on
it's something we've talked about for a
long time it's something that I think in
the people data world
this is something that should grow out
of the people data
in a world
you see what I'm saying
seems like it should also handle I mean
there are all sorts of other naming
conventions that places have like for
example
well yeah other than just first name
last name no I know Latin America you
know with right kinds of elaborate
things
right and yeah I think this should be
fed to Alan and people because this is
the place where this will start
will presumably be you know encoding our
people data in a way like this if we
care
makes sense to people
yeah makes sense to me
okay system status now this is something
we've talked about repeatedly right
well isn't this
I mean I suppose it depends on exactly
what information we want but isn't this
just the machine tab of system
information
I think so except that I think it
probably runs in real time
see what I'm saying I mean I think
that's some
uh
right I mean well so does system
information of machine or whatever is
the correct I don't think there's
anything here I think we can move
on young Tableau I think we finally got
this as a wfr right yep
I don't really know
whether there's anything beyond that
that we need right now
I don't think Young Tableau I think
there's sort of a
is there anything we particularly need I
mean it seems like we have some young
Tableau functionality well what uh what
about involutions
I think is Jose here I think yes so
there are many things that can be done
with jantaplos I mean they are fairly
specialized in the theory of
representations of groups
for example one thing that I would add
here is the little boot returns or rule
to multiply two gentle blocks
that's a standard computation but there
are many things that can be done with
them
but you think it's basically a WR story
for now yes for the moment yes yes
but but Brad's comment about Evolutions
is there's something in the permutation
system that should deal with evolutions
I needed them recently yeah I'm just
looking at the encyclopedia and it says
that
the number of involutions is also the
number of standard young Tableau within
so but but I understand but this is this
has a
I mean does an evolution count here and
that's fine in Dandy
I'm not sure that this the question is
is it useful to have a way of generating
permutations that comes from evolutions
because you know we have a bunch of
permutation functionality in the system
we don't have Evolution functionality in
the system
yeah and the involutions were in
combinatorica last time I checked and I
also I think parody pairings is now on
the function repository all right well
fine but okay look bottom line here is
and there's a question for Jose do we
think that there's an addition to the
built-in system functionality for
permutations that should include things
with evolutions
we could and there are I mean I have a I
have a full package to work with uh
jantaplos
and you see this type of thing that he
does yeah go ahead
are you sure yes
um okay so so this is
yeah so so there are lots of relations
with respect to partitions
and then
at this um looks to me like a a ripe to
be a packlet
yes yes this I mean and they have a nice
uh
um type settings
there are skew tableaus
[Music]
what is this this is part of exact yes
yes
[Music]
um
there
relations to various things and
manipulations of words some games
symmetric polynomials yes they are very
important in symmetric polynomials and
then various computations
these politicisms are like powers
and the little little bit richer rule is
the products
let's see if I have examples yes so this
is like multiplications
well this is quite magnificent I mean it
would be great to have this be a pattern
to expose some of these things in the
function Repository
um looks like a good project I mean
maybe that's a project uh
um
maybe it's something Brad could get
involved with at some point
and if there is a design I mean do you
think there is a built-in function
design that's in the making there or not
um well my point of view was always with
respect to manipulations of tensors this
could be generalized and made a thing by
itself
but it would require substantial work I
think so I think what we are thinking
about now
is a packlet with exposure of certain
functions through the function
Repository
okay
all right onward
you know this should be spherical not
sphere spherical distance spherical
Graphics Etc
in my opinion
I can update that
but I think this is a very fine thing
and I and I hope Brad is going to be
working on it
and it's similar to Geo but it's only
spheres and it's in Radiance right guys
yes there is also the relation with
Astra functionality so so we would have
like three families of functions that do
similar things so perhaps there is some
connection or we can use functions that
work in the three cases or something
I think so what would be the word I mean
if if we wanted to have if we had a
function that worked in all three cases
and we didn't want to you know make
three symbols for it what would we call
it I think it's a mistake I think that
they all have their own little tentacles
and I think people think of them
somewhat differently I mean I think
spherical you know I think this is
really for dealing with things on on
conceptual spheres
like spherical triangle is something
that we definitely want here
but spherical triangle on the sky or on
the earth is really not that important
so the only thing I I worry about is
situations where you know you kind of
have to convert from one to the other
because oh well there's this function
there's this what is fundamentally a
geometry operation and so that's why
it's only in the spherical world and not
in the Astro world but obviously you
could do it in the astral world and
maybe I I want to do it and so I have to
do some annoying conversion well we
should talk about how the conversions
work
I mean so in other words let's say you
have sparkle position and you say
geoposition of spherical position what
happens
I think that case is worse than the
Astro case because there's some issue
about obliteness right yeah I know right
right did Geo is the hardest you know
but we could have at least you know if
you say geoposition of spherical
position
you know it could simply take a uh a Geo
model that is a sphere
I mean it's going to do something
somewhat goofy because it's going to say
it's going to be a Geo model of a sphere
that has a you know radius of you know
whatever it is 6 000 kilometers or
whatever 8 000 kilometers well or maybe
one I mean you could just do what is it
Geo model error one I think it does that
doesn't it it makes a a you know a
spherical model of the diameter of one
meter or radius of one meter or
something that seems really horrifying
it would get all the same results as uh
you know spherical geometry functions
like spherical distance and so on would
presumably return
you know the well actually I guess
I think historical this is going to turn
the same thing as Geo distance but that
might be pretty bizarre I think it will
be crazy I think it's better to just
admit we live on the Earth
and convert if you do geoposition of
spherical position to just convert to
the corresponding angle position on the
Earth
I mean I think the Astro is a little
different because they're this genuine
spheres involved but again you know on a
sphere spherical whatever we're not
worrying about relativistic corrections
we're not doing any of that stuff it's
just a conceptual mathematical sphere
which itself will be very useful
and I have a feeling that other forms of
geometry like hyperbolic geometry we
might eventually want to have
you know hyperbolic distance and things
like that
just like go go ahead so so when you are
talking about this um uh ideal sphere so
it wouldn't have a radius
so it's not the radius one
as radius one spherical distance would
by default be radius one I would assume
but it would take also a radius just in
case you're going to yes absolutely yeah
okay
now and I think you're living on a
single sphere so you know anything that
is like you're going out into the region
world if you want to know the distance
between points on two different spheres
and all kinds of things like that
but we would have to distinguish and and
we do this in in our store already Aster
distance from Astro uh angular
separation
right because you want to
do you want to distinguish the distance
as an angle from the physical distance
right well so it's probably a spherical
angle difference or something
but I also think we really need
spherical triangles
which are you know definitely a thing
much more so than they are a thing on
Geo and all those kinds of places
right polygon
with three vertices right but
you know the spherical trigonometry that
we really want to support properly on a
sphere yep
all right let's keep going
all strings
oh sorry one more question uh if we're
gonna do spherical triangles would we do
hyperbolic triangles too I'd like to I'd
like to do hyperbolic geometry as well
yes
well I mean
I suppose we could do the distance right
but you can't embed hyperbolic geometry
in three dimension three euclidean
dimensions so right but then we but we
have a purely symbolic hyperbolic
distance and hyperbolic
you know
we have a whole set of hyperbolic
projections and so on you know the
hyperbolic geometry is actually useful
in classical algebraic geometry tooth
through the reborn uniformisation
theorem so there would be lots of
interesting examples well and also the
fact is that we can obviously have
projections we have models you know the
pancreat disk and so on you know it's
clearly useful because we can have
things where there are things that have
coordinates in hyperbolic space and then
we can render them in a kind of you know
hyperbolic
um
the analog of geolist plot hyperbolic
list plot
with projections it really does seem
like a useful thing to be thinking about
it's something you know it's a it's a
Well understood 150 year old kind of
mathematical concept of hyperbolic space
which I think we should support
particularly with the rendering through
projections and so on yeah Felix Klein
and all that indeed
um so I mean I think that's the you know
that Brad that's that's the future for
this project of yours with spherical
you know geometry trigonometry
hyperbolic
Etc
let's move on here
okay
this particular thing finds strings in a
byte array I assume that that's a WR
function already is it
if it isn't it should be
I don't think that makes any sense
well it's the same thing that strings
does in you know the Unix operating
system you take a binary and you look
for things which are coherent sequences
of ascii-like characters
yes in the world of modern Unicode it
makes less and less sense
and also if you you know if you've ever
run strings you know it returns a lot of
garbage in addition to meaningful stuff
indeed
this is not a profoundly important
function and I know people have worked
on the summer school and I'm sure we can
find one of those implementations and
turn it into a wfr and I think that's
what we should do
okay yeah
okay let's continue here
are these in wfr now yes
do we think we want to have these as
system functions
it seemed mildly useful but I haven't
been profoundly
well actually do we have
this is negative question do we have uh
like built-in uh functions for like
partial sums and partial products
well I I mean so so it Returns the list
of of uh you know if you have a a series
you know returns each sort of as it's
summing them up you know each element in
the series like the opposite of
differences
accumulate I'm just gonna say accumulate
but I don't think that's what you want
something more I mean or I mean
something with the syntax of some maybe
this isn't relevant to this but I mean
like like we have some but the question
is would there is there a version of
some that's like some list where it
Returns the list of the partial right
sounds
which is like what accumulate is to an
explicit list some list would be to a
symbolically specified set of list
elements
presumably you'd give it a length how
many you want or something like that
Christopher
um I'm guessing yeah I mean similar
syntax in other words you're not looking
for a symbolic representation well I
hope but this is basically like a
symbolic fold or symbolic fold list
where instead of the fold elements being
generated
by
you know explicitly you're imagining
there's a generator of the successive
fold elements
I guess I mean I I I was thinking this
is related to the function you have on
screen I don't think it's actually that
related I guess in some case it's just a
cumulative table
um in the products case I guess it's
fold of times of table or something so
I'm not sure it makes that much sense
okay do we care about built-in geometric
and arithmetic sequences so so we have
already power rank
power range
yeah
it's almost the same thing
yes I mean I think
the pers people who should be asked
about these uh Roger and the uh are
solve folk because I can imagine them
being excited about having symbolic
geometric sequences
where you can have geometric sequence
with symbolic parameters here and where
you can
um
including one where you don't have the
uh number of elements here
yeah it sounds like that would be
something that could work with a lazy
stuff too
it could but it's also relevant just for
the rsolving so can somebody feed that
please
to I guess it's Roger and Adam yeah
little chicken okay but otherwise
otherwise we're you know we've got
wfiles for this and we're good
um
should be done post version 11. well I
have to say this thing turned out to be
much Messier
um
than we expected and I think it's
happily in wfr and shouldn't go anywhere
else
okay
what the heck is this
and it isn't subsets
isn't this just something no it's um
keeping order
well
doesn't strike me as profoundly
important
uh
I don't see you have a similar functions
to heavily used in patterns
what they call it splits
and it also included an empty list like
in one of them
no because they're oh oh uh
empty list you can include two empty
lists yeah I was gonna say that that's
not well defined
no it's like you start with the you also
have a second argument to these
functions how many splits you want so
it's like least petitions two so can you
partition on
list no possible ordered
sub lists including an empty one right
but that's relevant for your patent
utilities
and it could be that the better way to
specify this is just by giving some
pattern and having it be able to
generate you know like triple blank
comma triple blank comma double blank or
something which is a richer language
that lets you specify things like oh I
want a minimum size partition of this
thing Etc et cetera Etc
how is it related to groupings
I'm not sure it's a good question
I don't think I'd be able to do this
with groupings
well in any case I don't think there's
any place to go with this here I think
this is happily to be our forward for
now
natural language string
I see
I mean this is kind of like the
synthesized like what Wolfman Alpha
notebook Edition does of synthesizing a
natural language input for something
I believe that there are functions like
this that Michael and those guys have
found useful can we ask them about this
please
they may already have some function like
this makes sense Avery take that
um
okay this thing is important and we've
never gotten around to it
um this is basically doing natural
language lookups on data sets
uh
this project should be in the global
project list
and it just it's something we need to
get to at some point
I don't think there's a a small
lightweight function to be built around
it
is this like the data container
stuff not quite this is this is
generated no it's it's more like
semantic import related it's part of the
Gaggle with semantic import
okay
and I don't know where that's getting
worked on I mean Jeremy I think was
working on some of that stuff
um but this is this is not dead and this
should we should make sure that this
gets you know attached to the
appropriate thing in the global project
list
yep I can do that
index by I have no clue what it is
anybody know
that's pretty much what the question
marks where we didn't have any extra
notes on that one so
I mean most of the talk we're talking
about these days with indexing has to do
with supplied so yeah let's just kill
that one I don't know
sequence select
what is this
I see
yeah it's kind of
but is it in wfr or is it not our
proposal was to put it in wfr
a lot of these suggestions predate wfr
existing obviously
right indexed there right
sorry does this consider every possible
subsequence
I think it can presumably considers
contiguous sequences yeah well the idea
sure
I mean this function
don't we already have sequence cases
yes
is it the same type of meaning
is the analogy does the analogy hold in
other words
yes although I guess that you want to
use you know double hash like instead of
hash if you know what I mean in sequence
select to be very consistent
I think I agree
actually sorry that wouldn't be
consistent with sequence cases I
misremembered because in those cases as
the list on the left-hand side of the
rule
but sequence select seems like it goes
naturally with sequence cases
yeah the the main difference though is
just that sequence cases can be a lot
smarter than sequence select can because
it you know it can use pattern matching
you know it can it can reason about the
pattern so it doesn't have to actually
consider all N squared cases or whatever
it is
but sequence cases is not contiguous
yes it is it is yeah
subset cases is the other one you are
thinking about oh yeah yeah right right
right right
which could have been maybe an orderless
version of sequence cases or is
effectively it is effectively okay
I don't know why sequence select doesn't
exist
it is
sorry go ahead I was going to say that
it's probably a historical thing we
created sequence cases positions and
count together and then split
and we didn't continue with with the
family
although I have to say I haven't missed
it
right well well and if we added it would
we also have to add it we also have
subset cases but we also have subset
select
let's put this in wfr and not worry
about it for right now
okay
um
who
who does that
what says bracket wfr does that mean
it's already in wfr no it doesn't that
means we're proposing to put it in wfr
rather than as a system function
so
I guess Avery you make a ticket and
so I mean this is does not look to me
like it's more than a 15-minute job
I'm sure it's more than a 15 minute job
then it may help in fact I think when
you say something like it's not more
than a 15-minute job that that that
makes it exponentially worse
okay fine I'm I'm convinced of that
um
I don't think this is high priority I
think it's one of these things that we
could have as a you know as a things to
put in wfr when when there's an
opportunity to do it
okay deep pattern is sort of interesting
and that has to do with head matching
I mean not as big it's being proposed
here
oh okay it doesn't die I see not
well maybe there could be a second
argument to the Deep pattern that's like
um matches the sequence of heads going
down or something like that
yeah I think there's a family of things
that we've never done
which is just like we have double blank
representing an arbitrary sequence of
things
in a sort of space-like direction we do
not have things in a tree-like Direction
we don't have a way of specifying a you
know if I have a thing where I'm saying
you know F of f of f of f of f of x
right we have no pattern that will match
that with an arbitrary sequence of F's
mm-hmm
yes and and F of bracket F of bracket f
I think we don't have that either
or or some other you mean this that that
type of thing yes
I mean with other symbols other than F's
what do you mean
but we don't have this particular thing
we don't have a way of saying dot dot
you know if this was list ffff
then we can just say F dot dot
and that will match that right but we
don't have a similar way we don't have
an analog of dot dot or blank blank that
represents tree like
you know that represents these tree-like
cases
so it probably should be
the instead of repeated something called
something like nested
indeed with the similar argument like
how many times you can lest this thing
yes
I think would be interesting to explore
you know I I don't know how difficult
such a thing would be to implement and
I do wonder whether it is relevant to
the generalization of up values which is
something we've been meaning to do for
35 years
in other words if we had such a thing
could it generalize up values
because right now up values are one
level you know you can say F of G of x
and you can associate that value with G
but if it's F of G of H of X you can
only go one level there
[Music]
I think this should be explored nested
you know these two cases
I think this is worth exploring and I
think that's deeply related to this
um you know it's a good
ilb LCC thing to explore
okay yeah we'll add it to the roadmap
okay
this wasn't proposed by Dave I assume
no
I do like this idea of naming functions
for long time employees
we have gray we have light blue which is
almost for me
huh so it is I'd never even noticed that
wow in all these years
the
um and and how is this different from
quiet
because it's a block
because it's temporary
so it's quiet
so it is
doesn't seem like it's different does it
and having a message off is different
from one that's quieted right I mean
it's probably rare that code cares
but it could be right
let's let's throw this into the um uh
error handling discussion it's probably
not relevant but just in case there's
something here let's put it in the error
handling
agenda
okay
well we've got this
this is threaded yeah
right yeah
initialization option for module I think
that's what we've got now with with
cleanup and so on isn't it
um that's what this seems to be hinting
at
I'm not absolutely sure but I think
that's what this is getting at okay
let's assume it
Max for rules
that just seems bizarre it's bizarre and
I think it's handled by association
well I don't know what it is but it
seems bizarre to me
pattern equal
ah
well this is something related to Nick's
pattern unification work
and I mean there's a whole gaggle of
pattern utility functions which we
definitely are interested in
but then I think that that the the
pattern utility functions if they're not
in the global project list they should
be and there's a gaggle of them
and Nick I think already has drafts of a
bunch of them
that's where this should be
infix match queue
I'm not it's not floating my boat
post set
isn't that
I I have not been using this thing but
isn't isn't the um
isn't slash equals something like this
no
right because it right that applies
something to X and Returns the new value
right that's no different from x equals
f of x
FSS equal x
what are you say I guess X slash equal f
is equal to
x equals f of x this is saying
well you're saying if I say x x equals
list ABC and then I say x slash slash
equals reverse
right missing a slash but what where
where am I Michelle slash uh before
slash equals isn't that right no it's
last slash equals
you just divided by
foreign
what the heck I did here right you
divided all the elements by reverse
okay and now I've got this
has anybody been using this thing
a little I like it yeah
okay good well I'm glad it's got some
fans
okay so this is right this is saying you
do x equals you have x equals one and
then you have
x equals 2x and it returns 1 instead of
two which I suppose is
theoretically useful and but I I have a
hard time getting excited about this I'm
my vote is not being floated here
let's move on
um
I don't know anybody excited about this
seems hard to Define
yes I think length is too important to
to complicate
agreed
don't we have this now I have this right
that's uh yeah remaining time remaining
yeah
yeah so it's a it's a
way time remaining
um polls that
there's some time constraint
yeah yeah so if I say time constrained
of
time remaining comma five you should get
five or very close to five
out of curiosity does time remaining
work inside of functions with the time
constraint option
good question
well it should I would guess yes it
should detect the nearest time
constraint I would guess that those are
implemented using time constrained
well but they're ones like I mean this
is a pretty impossible case but I mean
there's stuff like full simplify for
example which has a time constraint
which I think only
you know it was constrains of how long
it spends in each branch and weird stuff
like that right so something would tell
you how much it is doing is if you could
somehow get that into full simplify it
would tell you how much time remains in
the current transformation that's being
attempted well you can it could be a
side effect of some kind of thing okay
this looks good but we can by the way
Avery in in annotating this please note
when these things were implemented right
just so we know that for if we ever come
back to this notebook
okay I can go through and update that or
at least where what they're implemented
as yes
well you know we decided it was a bad
idea or whatever else okay string
difference
I think that seems like a sequence
alignment thing yeah I was thinking
isn't that something we have or with
various methods
distance metrics I think we do I think
we should ignore that okay yeah
is this in wfr or is it not it's not
currently in wfr it is you know you can
basically select things from word list
based on a part of speech our proposal
was just to have a wfr function for
vowels consonants syllables Etc
but now there's two things in the
there's string vowels which presumably
gets the vowels from you know the list
but it's the idea of the first thing to
be to give you the list of vowels that
are used in English yeah and I don't
understand why English vowels which I
got here was capital letters that seems
just completely wrong to me
I have to say I would argue that this
could be an actual just like we have
alphabet
you know it just seems like a useful
thing to have the list of vowels the
list of consonants
they're really pretty I mean or possibly
that it is part of alphabet yeah I mean
that's what I was going to suggest just
like random word right you can say part
of speech then alphabet you should be
able to say
um
oh look there's a two argument form okay
well what does it do
that gives you properties associated
with it but it doesn't say what they are
[Music]
which is a bit upsetting here
foreign
it's simply not freaking documented here
okay this needs to be fixed
okay I'll take a look at that I'm
guessing that's in oversight from
Constantine but yeah I'll go through and
figure out that probably you should be
right we probably need just a better
scope section and not hide this and
generalizations and extensions well and
we also need it in the documentation at
the top here just so okay well I agree
with that but right but I mean to me
alphabet
English common vowels is not crazy I
mean given that this says index
characters
right and I'm I'm very confused here
that that that that is capital letters
there I don't understand that at all
yes and these are properties of alphabet
comes from the entity values and I think
we should we could add the vowels and
consonants there
as properties in the same we have these
index characters these shouldn't be
capital letters here
there's no reason why index characters
should be capital letters I think unless
there's some special thing about indexes
foreign
automatic as a first argument that's the
same as zero argument for
I would assume yes I don't know what
happens if you do this in if if I set
the language to to um I don't know
French or something do I get a different
alphabet put alphabet open close
well what options what's options of
alphabet
so
what you'll get
okay long I always said that we will use
English as uh
I think we should I think we should use
English as a default
all right so Francisco and others please
check into this I don't think it's
totally obvious that we shouldn't have a
vowels open close
I think it's such a common thing it
seems like it might be useful and there
are enough kind of like neat little
algorithms that make use of the vowels
Etc
that it seems worthwhile to me
potentially right but that could be a
handy function calling alphabet behind
because yes that's fine all right so
Francisco can you look at this and look
at the I mean the you know there's
clearly a goof up with this here
right right yeah we should explain that
the properties are the purposes from The
Entity type alphabet yep well we should
list them here is what we should do
look somewhere else
oh and probably linking to see also the
the alphabet entity type yes for sure
yes it's not there yeah it's goofed up
so we'll fix it
oh boy
these are things for string matching
right
yeah they would basically correspond to
regular Expressions well I certainly do
not support having Japanese character I
mean yeah you could I I could possibly
you know accept as the character and
non-ascii or printing character versus
non-printing character but
well you could have cut Agana hiragana
as proper character sets which there are
no I understand
where's my cuneiform character or
something like that yeah no that's
rapidly devolves
right
look I think here that what we should do
is we should have instead of all of
these different things we should have a
generic
uh you know character match I don't know
what we should call it well it's
character character class character
pattern it's the standard term well fine
so let's just do that character class
ASCII character class Japanese that
seems highly sensible to me
and it doesn't evaluate right it doesn't
evaluate
well one other thing that's
well one other quick question is so
I was looking at alphabet where we're
talking about this so in alphabet you
know right so one thing is you might
want this to relate to alphabet where
it's similar to Alternatives at at
alphabet but there are differences
because there are some languages that
make hair splitting distinctions about
whether they're umlauted letters are
actually letters or whether they're just
letters of diacritical marks
um so like for example alphabet of
German doesn't show any of the umlauts
but Swedish does and I think that's a
real distinction the languages make it's
not I don't think it's a bug but then
no that was created yes yes oh all
therefore it's working yeah right but
I'm saying just that you know maybe this
is something that may already be in this
undocumented second argument of alphabet
but presumably there should be a way of
getting the actual list of all the
characters that you that this pattern
matches if that makes sense yeah like
give me all of the characters including
the um mounts even if they're not
letters just give me all the characters
that you would expect to see in German
text
right so there's probably a character
class
or something character class members or
some such other thing
that's the second argument alphabet but
there's two different things here one is
introducing character class in the
string patterns World which does seem
worthwhile to me and definitely is what
we do instead of the millions of these
right
yeah we have a few special ones that are
that are you know have their own thing
but otherwise it's just the generic
character class
and otherwise
support
describing whatever it is a character
whatever is a valid character class
should be capable of being
listed by some alphabet thing
I mean arguably you said to say alphabet
of character class or blah and that
would be one way to do it
right we have these full characters
property also for alphabet which is kind
of similar we don't have any freaking
properties for alphabet because we
didn't document any of them I I know I
know about it there is these full
characters
but nobody's ever going to have known
that I mean how did that happen
that we just didn't document it come on
outside
are the character classes just going to
be Unicode blocks
well they're not contiguous ones
more complicated
irregular Expressions under the hood
and I don't know what this is I've never
seen this before
real all right well I guess Francisco
you're a native Spanish speaker I mean
do those diet critical combinations
actually appear in Spanish what the heck
is this for English no yeah the problem
is that for example when I was looking
at this Property they include everything
that will be valid in a document for
example and because the European Union
considers all the characters valid in
documents they include for example all
the special characters in English in in
excuse me I mean this is like Ethel red
you know I'm sure Ethel red is now is
the you know compatibility with a
thousand years ago can be written with
with like this right or more than a
thousand years ago
I mean that's not English
is it no that's right so that's the list
of all the characters that might appear
in documents that are valid and um
according to Ethel Fred
that was bad I believe he was something
now it was just derived empirically by
just looking at a bunch of text and
getting the letters out or
where did this come from I'm not sure
that comes also from the cldr project
okay
and maybe now that brexit has happened
the set of full characters in English
might
English is still official in the UA so
yeah
no I don't know they probably have
Danish I don't know
um
okay right probably we will need a
greater list of uh actor characters with
the valid combinations of native words
that's fine so there's work to be done
here let's we'll yes I agree yeah
okay let's move on a bit set file
attributes I thought we had that that's
the chamod type functionality I thought
we'd built that finally
I haven't found
that functionality implemented I mean
Constantine added ways to read it so if
you do like information a file of
something you'll get the file attributes
listed out but seems useful I mean it's
not the highest priority but it seems
useful
um
I think we should preserve that as the
thing we want could that also extend to
set permissions having file as a first
argument yes but I mean yeah that was
the problem that we ran into right that
the permissions as you know defined by
the cloud is different from permissions
on the file
systems ambiguous I personally think
what we should do is just say set
permissions and this P string thing
should work for files and if we can
convert some of the cloud permissions
symbolic structure to the desktop so be
it but what we can't convert we should
just error out on
to what I'm saying I mean something like
this read owner read write execute
that we can do
you know
so yeah I mean we're gonna have to have
error handling no matter what fruit yeah
so I think we should try and put it in I
agree I'm I'm changing my mind I agree
we should try and put into set
permissions and just have it work as
best it can given that there is a p
string thing here anyway
foreign
example of that
surely we Show an example oh gosh I
think oh for goodness sake come on guys
okay another bug okay nobody here is
responsible for cloud documentation
I don't think this is cloud but I mean
this is yes yes this is this is
exclusively for cloud objects
yeah those two examples and basic
examples covered I think for public and
private
oh I see that that's what they mean by
strings not
you know you know rwx yeah right
okay this requires an investigation and
perhaps we can you know we have to
decide if we're supporting rwx or
whatever it is
for the cloud
and perhaps we need a separate thing set
file permissions I'm not sure requires
investigation but this is alive
all right let's try and do just a couple
more I mean I mean this was on the LCC
agenda so I don't know why why that
wasn't noted here but
okay what was the Goof a minor goof okay
and activate complete
I don't think this this is another
angels
you know
impenetrable irresistible forces
immovable objects Etc type situations
and I don't think we should I don't
think there's any more I don't think
there's anything useful we can get from
doing that further
inflected forms is a long time project
that we really want to see done
Francisco maybe you could speak to that
that's a linguistic curation project
right yes I I think that will be related
to all the things we are doing about
language data Etc
okay so I'm going to assume you will
take this
and we'll see that and and it should be
in the global project list
uh
this is currently a lower priority from
2017.
because that's for
right because also there was this
project of War data that they were
factoring all these World entity type
that's under Alliance actually but yes I
can agree with him phonemes
now I thought we were making this active
because now it was being dovetailed with
the audio stuff
I haven't heard that part of the
discussion I mean we talked some years
ago about phonemes and phones as being
linguistic data
this this is supposedly active Alan
Johan should be consulted on this uh we
also started uh designing a an entity
type for phonemes but we never finished
that
so so maybe we should continue that is
what should be done yeah
cyclical rise
we have discussed this multiple times
and I think it's something that deserves
further discussion and it's possibly
related to the future of arrays project
what what is this exactly this is more
like a structure array type
okay um and and I think John will get at
some point it's just that he's working
on more important linear algebra related
structure types
is it in fact of that type I mean is it
cyclic array
would be a rapper you're saying
yes so we store one block and then we
say this is a block of three by three
but they array is a million by a million
and he knows how to extract any element
Etc
so it's a little bit related to a
templates Matrix or something like that
it's the same kind of idea storing a
much smaller piece of information
yeah and we've got I mean even yesterday
we were reviewing bandalon matrices and
things like this so this seems like a
concept that is much simpler than many
of these other algebra type Concepts
so it seems like a good thing so you say
this is on the on the path yes I think
it is let's make sure that this that we
know that okay cyclic array is probably
the the name that we want for it
um how are we doing here let's see
did we ever get this
I haven't seen a fully functional
version of it I know there were
discussions of this with
at various points in the past but I
haven't seen a user maybe we in fact
have this but from having external
evaluate maybe we built this or maybe we
should just expose it
but I think we at least have import
string for these I think I've used it
[Music]
okay well so somebody investigate please
ask the import export Team every I think
that's for you
yep got it
this whole thing this is something we've
asked for for millions of years
it still seems useful to me
comments
okay I would find it useful too
and being able to read numbers in ease
and these notations yeah
I think we want this
all right we should wrap here
um to be continued another time
this has been a useful I mean it's
actually fairly encouraging I mean a lot
of the stuff we've discussed here has
either been done or
you know this is this is really good
uh
okay yeah we'll follow up on those items
and I mean I don't know how much when we
get down to something like this
none of these sections are enormous
[Music]
um
even like regions or Charles or a
handful of things so when we get there
we'll have those individual people here
as well
the second largest group is the uaf one
I see this is all sensible stuff that
this is really good for us to go through
this
all right thanks a lot everybody and uh
see you later